hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website column today we're going
to be continuing our coverage of the
2014 rapid Chess Championships we're in
round 12 right now Magnus Carlsen has a
small advantage over vision on by half a
point if he can go ahead and win this
with only three matches left definitely
well on his way to potentially actually
winning the 2014 rapid Chess
Championships which would be crazy since
he just won the regular chess
championship so very important match he
does have the white pieces against
vision on playing the black pieces so
definitely going to be an interesting
match as both players are definitely
trying to get as many points as possible
Magnus Carlsen starts with pawn to d4
the the Queen pawn opening Queen to d5
we have the Queen's Gambit and we see
the slob defense respond by vision on
right here after the capture Knight to
c3 we do see an interesting move for
Magnus Carlsen he plays Bishop here to
f4 you're pretty much always going to
see Knight to f3 in this particular case
but changing it up a little bit Magnus
Carlsen definitely knows a lot of
different openings and you can always
transpose into some of the same lines
but maybe trying to catch his opponent
off guard by playing a bishop here to f4
pretty early vishal responds with Knight
to c6 pawn III solidifying opening up
the door for the LightSquared Bishop
Bishop to f5 sort of looks like vision
on is just kind of marrying exactly what
Magnus Carlsen is doing rook to c1
getting it into this open fire right
here on the C file definitely where you
want your Brooks to be Vishu responds
with the same thing Knight to f3 we kind
of look at it this is about as equal as
you are going to get both sides have
virtually the same setup of vichy
decides to go ahead and complete that
with pawn here to e6 oh yes white has
the next move coming but both sides
pretty much equal in this position
because they've just been marrying each
other on board so we now see Queen here
- a b3 a little bit active bishop - abby
force of issue decides he wants to not
quite get his queen involved bishop here
to b5 magnus carlsen still wants to do
exactly what his opponent is doing as
well we do see the bishop take so
magnus carlsen is going to have a double
bishop pair he takes back with his pawn
it's always important to know what you
should take back with with pawns you
want to be taking back towards the
center rook would be actually somewhat
of a mistake here then his opponent can
play Knight to e4 attacking let's say
the route comes back here to see one
Queen to a5 all of a sudden it gets
pretty tricky for White's position black
has much more aggression going on this
particular setup right here so probably
much better that he decided to take with
his pawn and then castle on the kingside
magnus carlsen eventually needs to go
ahead and castle because right now i
doesn't have as much safety we see the
bishop takes the magnus carlsen no
longer has the bishop pair queen takes
up here on a b7 trying to gain some
materials to magnus carlsen is up
material on board but it definitely gets
interesting from here so Queen to c8
actually baiting his opponent to play
Queen to a7 and especially in a rapid
chess tournament it kind of has to send
your alarms off there there's no reason
that vision on would just give up
material but it kind of takes a little
bit to figure out you know what he would
be up to if Queen takes here on a7 this
is kind of a poisoned pawn you're going
to see rook to c3 and this is going to
be very bad the rook needs to stay kind
of close with rook here to d1 so that
the rook doesn't come down here to to c1
he has protection by this Queen here on
c8 so he doesn't have too many options
but after the rook comes to a d1 Bishop
to c2 is going to be very very bad for
Magnus Carlsen so he picks right instead
these decides to go ahead and gobble up
this material here on c8 we now see the
rook swinging over very important to now
double up the rooks here to attack this
pawn here on c3 because again vision on
is down a material but he can get that
back if and when he wants to we see
Knight to e5 nice little outpost move
for the knight doesn't really matter
vision odds coming down to take material
and now vision on has a pretty active
position both sides are equal in
material but this rook is a lot more
active it's not going to be too
difficult for Magnus
and to get his rook involved into the
game so I would say it's about equal
maybe right now Black has a very very
small advantage
Magnus Charleston now plays castle on
the King side which you doesn't have a
whole lot of options the rook can just
come down here to see one that's going
to be bad so really you need to be
castling in the first place get your
rook involved into the game pawn to h6
pawn to h4 both sides just kind of
jockeying for position here Knight to e4
s opponent has a nice little outpost and
so does black right here pawn to g4
Magnus Carlsen is looking to extend an
attack on the King side Vishy Anand not
having any of that rook swinging over
here to b1 so Magnus Carlsen is getting
some counter play with his own rook he
has a fairly aggressive position as well
so that's going to be fine for him we do
see an exchange of pawns the bishop
comes back here so both sides again
somewhat same setup this rook is
attacking the rook forced to move so it
comes back here g7 nice little safe
Square now attacking the pawn here on a7
bishop coming back to e4 nice lob post
again I'll post in the middle of the
board tend to do a lot better than on
the side of the board it's not bad if
they're on the side but they usually
just do a lot better on board now
because the night here on e5 is also
protecting the square on f7 white
decides to go ahead and take here on f7
checking his opponent the king is forced
to come back here to g8 and then Magnus
Carlsen continued to push his forward so
he is up in material trying to force his
action a little bit we do see an
exchange right here and then Magnus
Carlsen takes back with his minor piece
and this is an interesting setup right
here going into the endgame so Magnus
Carlsen has four pawns to his opponents
four pawns he does have two minor pieces
his opponent has a rook so vichy nons
going to be looking to get back some of
that material it's going to be very
difficult for Magnus Carlsen to hang on
to his pawn over here but then Magnus
Carlsen should have a pretty easy rest
of the game to gobble up these pawns
get his King active in the game and
really just block vichy and on offer
from doing
too much on board we now see rook to c1
king's forced to come up and then that
pawns going to fall back and once you
have a passed pawn with vision on does
he understands his one chance of winning
is pushing this pawn up the board and
getting a queen here on a once that's
what he's going to be focused on Magnus
Carlsen again as we talked about he can
use his minor pieces to just gobble up
this material so his first move is going
to be taking here on a g5 he can X take
here on e6 and just continue down pawn
to a4 again there's no real threat the
rooks not doing too much it's not very
active here so Magnus Carlsen can easily
gobble up this material here on e6 and
continue interesting though in the game
Magnus Carlsen played King to d1 kind of
let his foot off the gas after the game
he mentioned that the next few moves
from him just completely were terrible
definitely wishes he could take them
back now rook to b2 and this gets a
little interesting because now if Magnus
Carlsen decides to take on e6 then the
route can come up to a b6 and one of
these pieces is going to fall Magnus
Carlsen in game was one move late and
does decide in fact to take with his
night here on e6 so rook to b6 and then
another mistake the knight comes back
here to f4 now one thing he could have
done to save face a little bit he could
have played King here to c2 and then
after the rook takes on d6 we can have
Knight to c5 nice little outpost going
to gain this material back on board all
of a sudden this white King is pretty
active it's going to be very difficult
for black to hold on and when White has
a pretty good game here he can
eventually take this pawn right here and
they can just start to push his pawns up
the board but instead he plays the
questionable Knight to f4 yes it is
attacking this pawn but rook taking here
on d6 also defend this pawn Magnus
Carlsen said in the particular you know
after press conference that this was
kind of his fatal mistake right here and
he had flashes of going back to a few
years ago when he was dominating a big
tournament and just plummeted the rest
of the way and ended up losing so things
are definitely not looking good trying
to come out with a draw in this
particular match the works going to
swing over here to be six again machine
on is going to start pushing forward and
so both sides just kind of jockeying
White's really trying to keep this pond
from going anywhere further vision on is
trying to keep at the king from moving
past this B file and at the same time
getting his cane involved into the game
so we can kind of stop these put these
pawns if Magnus Carlsen decides he wants
to put those push those forward pawn to
e4 Magnus Carlsen there's no way right
now to attack this pawn so we need to go
ahead and start pushing with his pawns
you know King to f7 centralizing in game
you always want to get your kings
involved they can be a very very
valuable piece King to c1 and not too
many moves now the King can't come over
or he could come to be one but then he's
going to lose his knight right here the
rooks usually belong behind your pawns
so they can kind of push forward this
Knights kind of relegated to defense
mode right here coming back here to b7
again b7 is very crucial because he
wants to keep the King from moving over
here once the Kings over here he can
kind of go wherever and take this
material on board so rook to a b7
pushing forward a little bit's there's
no way to hold on to all this material
and so we do have the pawn come up here
to g7 but again the rook on b8 is still
kind of holding on to that so rook over
here taking on g8 now the king can come
over and start to attack but another
dagger on board is a rook to g3
attacking and also protecting this pawn
both sides do continue to move a little
bit all vision ons trying to do is to
get his King involved into the action
he's going to kind of take the long way
around the board but Magnus Carlsen can
just kind of move his pieces around
cannot stop the pressure the eventual
promotion
spawn unless he wants to give us give up
his night and the Vietnam would just
have a rook in a king so magnus carlsen
and this particular game loses vision
han goes up a half a point going into
round three good news is magnus carlsen
would redeem himself and go on to win
the tournaments by having a great last
few games so congratulations to magnus
carlsen for somehow winning the 2014
rapid Chess Championships we have the
Blitz portion going on Thursday and
Friday is definitely gonna be interested
to see who wins that but hopefully you
guys enjoyed this video learn something
and I'll see you guys in the next one
thanks for watching